thanks very much Nick
all of you for your interest in my work
coming before you you see
here which is on the wall of the commune
a the Town Hall of Siena Italy and it
depicts what the author said was a
situation of good government it's the
1st 14th century statement about what
good government might mean that is
entirely secular and Lorenzetti wrote it
painted this quite deliberately to
depict how we ought to think about the
problem of government in a way which
took account of ethics and morals but
was detached from the usual religious
imagery now I can't begin without saying
Who I owe thanks to for this work sandra
Polonia is a experimental economists
from bogota and you can also see she's
there she's finished an experiment with
these street vendors in Bogota but she
cannot resist explaining to them how
they would actually be better off if
they learned how to cooperate the Sun ha
Y is a just received his degree in his
PhD in mathematics from University of
Massachusetts and we've written a number
of papers on which I will draw here and
I want to thank both Sandra and some ha
for their contribution to this work now
what we and very many other people in
behavioral economics are trying to do is
trying to take some of the new findings
in these areas and address them to
standard questions in political theory
law and economics standard economics
that is the heyday of behavioral
economics is over I mean we've had a lot
of fun with the low-hanging fruit
showing that the standard model in
economics is wrong and that has been an
enjoyable occupation for the last decade
and a half
but of course somebody's bound to say
sooner or later so what how would you do
economics differently or how would you
do philosophy differently if you really
thought that the kinds of findings that
are now I think quite agreed upon we're
really the case and I intend to
contribute to that project here today
and Thursday and Beyond on Monday now
I'm going to start in a well-trodden
path beginning with Aristotle he asked
us to think that law givers make the
citizen good
inculcating habits in them and this is
the aim of every law giver if he does
not succeed in doing that his
legislation is a failure it is this it
is in this that a good Constitution
differs from a bad one he doesn't say
this is one of the characteristics of a
good Constitution he says this is the
characteristic of a good Constitution I
mentioned that this is work in progress
because I literally received some data
just today that went into the lecture I
can't say I thought very carefully about
every single piece of it and that's why
I ask you to please be in touch with me
right here today by email I really need
your ideas I need your help these are
very big and challenging questions and
I'm sure I can't answer them all or
answer them well without your help this
is of course a picture of Machiavelli
and there is a development during this
period in which the idea is that good
laws replace good citizens as the Sienna
qua non of good government and here
sorry here is what Machiavelli said he
said all men are wicked hunger and
poverty makes them industrious and laws
make them good now I want to be careful
with this because it sounds like he has
some view of human nature as being
malign and he doesn't what he says
before this he says if you want to found
a republic you better assume that all
men are wicked it is said that hunger
and poverty make them industrious in
laws make them good I'll come back to
this because he was not really making a
statement about human nature he was
making a statement about how we should
make laws but the key point here and of
course the difference with Aristotle and
many others is that Machiavelli had the
idea that we should try to design
governments for ordinary citizens with
what he called natural and ordinary
humors neither particularly good or bad
simply the shabby motives that are quite
common among all of us and the idea is
to try to find a set of laws and
constraints and incentives which would
induce people like that with natural and
ordinary humors to behave
well and of course this is there's a
long tradition then starting with
another Italian Marci Leo with Hobbes
Mandeville Humes myth and Bentham and
others and notice here this is not the
usual distinction that you find in
political theory and philosophy between
people who thought that human nature was
nearly good or bad that's not the
distinction I'm making so please don't
misunderstand the point it's that all
these people have in common whatever
they thought about human nature the idea
that you should design laws and
incentives so that people with ordinary
motives could actually coordinate their
activities in a way which led to some
kind of decent result now one of the
most striking developments in the social
sciences philosophy political theory was
introduced by a guy who was a doctor and
probably not thought of as a political
theorist his name was Bernard Mandeville
he wrote a book called the fable of the
bees it was about bees because had it
been about people it would have been
even more scandalous than it was when it
was written which was 1705 the first
edition he wrote about a hive of bees
that were very vice phille every part
was full of ice yet the whole mass of
paradise such were the blessings of that
state their crimes conspired to make
them great the worst of all the
multitude did something for the common
good the subtitle of the first edition
1705 was human frailties maybe turned to
the advantage of civil society and made
to supply the place of moral virtue so
or again this idea of ordinary motives
frailties - Mandeville the normal humors
- to Machiavelli
now you'll see the progression here it's
not a very large jump from Mandeville to
Smith with the invisible hand and his
famous passage in which he says it is
not the benevolence of the butcher the
brewer or the Baker that we expect our
dinner but from their regard for their
own self-interest and there you see
probably the most radical idea in
economics ever announced which is that
this radical disjunction between motives
and consequences which could sum
be permissible and something which we
should do because we have a set of
institutions which would make it be so
that the worst of all the multitude
would do something for the common good
that's the idea of the invisible hand
just translating some of Mandeville's
poetry into Smith's economics and from
there of course one can easily develop
the ideas made famous by Hume and
Bentham this passage from Hume is really
a wonderful idea political writers have
established it as a maxim that in
contriving any system of government
every man ought to be supposed to be a
knave and to have no other end in all of
his actions in his private interest by
this interest we must govern him and by
means of it make him notwithstanding his
insatiable avarice and ambition
cooperate to the public good Bentham in
what is probably the first textbook in
what we now call public economics asked
about how we design the incentive so
that public servants will do their jobs
well and he said what he called he
actually italicized this he called it
the duty and interest Junction principle
make it every man's interest to observe
that conduct which it is is his duty to
observe now notice again this is
definitely Machiavelli this is
Mandeville and Smith this is not
Aristotle he does not say we should
organize the public sector so the public
servants want to do well have the
commitment to the loyalty to the
citizens solidarity with them to do well
but rather we should give them
incentives in their own private self
regarding ways to do the job well now we
know of course that virtue and it looks
like we're on a trajectory here that you
can dispense with virtue just design
these institutions right and they're
probably some in this room have had a
hand at that economics does it quite a
bit but I think it's now quite
uncontroversial in modern microeconomics
that there are many situations in which
we have what are called incomplete
contracts that is we don't have the
information where the information cannot
be used in a court of law to enforce
some aspect of some social interaction
which we care
whether it's the quality of the job how
hard the person works or more more
external things like environmental
pollution we have a hard time writing
contracts in these things
and in fact even in a place where you
would think there's no problem with the
question of an order or being in order
that's a quote from a friend of mine who
was a green beret and he I was I was
telling him years ago about what I was
studying in microeconomics and I said
you know the amazing thing is that you
look at a firm even a very well-run firm
it looks like orders are just carried
out he said you know when I was in
training this is the thing they stressed
all the time never given order unless
you know what what you're going to do
when it is disobeyed now in the cases
where you can't be sure that the
interests of the principal the officer
or the manager are going to be carried
out
we have incomplete contracts that is to
say the self-regarding preferences sorry
other regarding preferences such as
things like a work ethic reciprocity and
so on trust underwrite exchanges which
would not take place otherwise because
you if you can't trust somebody and you
can't enforce a contract with them well
there are a lot of things you wouldn't
do with that person in other words
handshakes make things happen we have
more of a handshake economy than we
really have a peace rate economy today
and what this means is that our economy
works well not only because we have good
contracts they can never be so good as
to dispense with the ethics or other
regarding preferences of the individuals
this is Ken arrow I was saying that in
absence of trust opportunities for
mutually beneficial cooperation would
have to be forgone norms of social
behavior including ethical and moral
codes may be reactions of society to
compensate for market failures now aside
from the fact that it seems that he
seems to be proposing that market
failures existed first and then social
norms came afterwards which I would
object to I think it's a very sensible
statement about the importance of norms
and
non self-interested preferences in a
modern economy and because he's such a
hero I have to show you his picture now
the good news of course is that so
review so far there is this train going
down the tracks towards the dispensing
with morality and ethics entirely but
then it sort of ran into this wall of
the necessarily incomplete nature of
contracts and then and with arrows
affirmation oh we need these things and
so what's that sounds like it could be
bad news but it's not bad news because
these things are very common things like
reciprocity trust work ethic and so on
are not at all rare I don't want to I
mean there's there are hundreds and
hundreds of experiments and I've
reviewed probably hundreds and hundreds
that's probably if the true statement
some people have tried to extract from
these behavioral experiments the type of
the individuals now it's not always easy
to do not every experiment allows that
but in in a good many of them it is
possible and a a recent paper not so
reason by fair injector they estimated
that around half of the experimental
subjects are motivated by reciprocity I
returned a favor even if I could get
away with not returning it something
like between twenty and thirty percent
are self regarding a typical assumption
of economics and the most recent
research that I've seen on this which is
what I got today by a very large-scale
study suggests that that latter fraction
maybe more like one-fifth that is 20
percent there are very few people in
experiments who are consistently selfish
now long ago George Lowenstein another
economist but it writes usually with
psychologists this is a paper in a
psychology journal he categorized people
more or less using the same technique
found the twenty-nine were what he
called ruthless competitors would more
or less correspond to what we assumed in
economics there there are a good number
of Saints who are extremely generous and
there are a good number of loyalists the
loyalists are more like reciprocate errs
now I want to introduce how this looks
actually when you do an experiment
because I'm gonna be introducing quite a
few experiments and here's one of a
what's called a public goods game I
imagine many of you heard of the public
goods game but those of you who haven't
it's a prisoner's dilemma played with
many people so it's a game of
cooperation in which you can contribute
to the public good for example
voluntarily paying a tax or something of
that nature but the game is set up so
that you're better off if everybody else
pays and you don't so what's called the
dominant strategy in game theory that is
the thing which is the best thing for
you to do whatever everybody else does
is to withhold your contribution
now here's an experiment I'll come back
to the question of how these experiments
are run because I'm sure some of you are
not entirely familiar with that and some
of you who are familiar have some doubts
about it I want to deal with that a bit
later so here's an experiment in which
this is the average contribution they
they receive 20 tokens which get turned
into euros these are Swiss people and/or
I there's our German I think I forget
which they start out with 20 and they
can give some amount to the public pot
now they the public pot is like paying a
tax or you can keep it yourself there
are three treatments here the partner is
when you play suppose us here a were a
group of five and we're gonna play
together again and again and again of
course we don't know the names of each
other and up until now up until the
halfway through the game we don't even
know who contributed what we don't even
know by number who contributed what
that's the partner treatment I just know
I'm going to be with the same people
then we have the stranger treatment in
which the parties are shuffled after
every round the perfect stranger
treatment is just an extra specially
careful stranger treatment in which
obviously there's some possibility when
you shuffle you'll be with somebody in
the same group and they just they
actually use up a lot of subjects this
way but they make sure that you don't
ever be in a group with the people you
are in the group with before well you
can see what happens this this
punishment permitted thing here is is
the variation in the game that makes it
interesting at the end of each round say
round one it what you see on your screen
is it said
individuals a B and C and D in your
group
I'm individual II contributed the
following amounts and you just see the
number after that it says would you like
to say it would you like to take any of
your your payoffs and use that to punish
one of the other people in your group
the word punish is never used it just
says would you like to use some of your
payoffs to reduce somebody else's
payoffs I think probably most of the
people think of that as kind of like a
fine or something that they're gonna
find people who didn't contribute and
sure enough they do it and so what
happens is you start off about half and
half and then in this treatment you
actually increase quite a bit here you
sustain a lot of cooperation and that's
because what happens in the first couple
of rounds is people aren't contributing
very much then they get punished and
here they shape up and here they just
continue they don't trail off now what
happens in the tenth period is they say
okay no more punishments gonna be
allowed we're not going to tell you who
did what you just have to play the game
but the stranger and perfect stranger
and partner treatment are retained and
what happens is as you can see
contributions collapse people just don't
contribute and if you continue on they'd
get almost down to zero here okay now
think about this contributing as I said
is a it's an altruistic act the dominant
strategy is not to contribute so it
doesn't mean you have to guess it
anybody else does you just shouldn't do
it if you're selfish and also punishing
somebody is also an altruistic act
imagine you're in the perfect stranger
stranger treatment so this round has
happened and you see that somebody gave
nothing and you know next period you're
not going to be in the group of that
person now you're gonna pay money so as
to punish that person sure a lot of
people do so look at this part of the
graph somehow you cannot sustain
cooperation apparently because people
get angry at the ones who aren't
contributing once you have the
opportunity to punish the ones who
aren't contributing people punished like
crazy and by the way they get a
tremendous pleasure out of it if you
talk to people you know why did you do
that
weren't you throwing away money they'll
tell you just how much they how much fun
they had making sure that these scumbags
didn't get away with it
and so there's a lot of effect and I
want to come back to that is I mean are
these things highly cognitive or are
they just angry or they're responding
and so on but we'll get to that in any
case this is a very very common result
results like they've noticed there's two
kinds of altruism here going on but the
most interesting one is in the punishing
because in the punishing and the perfect
stranger treatment you just shouldn't be
doing it now this also says here
something I'll come back to at the end
and again in my third lecture people
start out wanting to contribute but it
but it gets here Oded so these the the
desire to be a contributor and a
cooperator is an extraordinarily fragile
motive and if you feel other people
aren't matching you you tend to withdraw
now the so that's the good news I guess
that the social preference are quite
common and that we shouldn't be overly
concerned having red arrow in thinking
that the economy which we now know
cannot dispense with morals is going to
be stuck with a bunch of immoral
citizens but there's a there is a
problem here
the classical writers they didn't assume
people were immoral I think about Smith
Theory of Moral Sentiments think about
Hume the passage by human that I quoted
the immediately after that he says it
may seem odd that an axiom should be
true in politics when it's false in fact
the axiom about the knaves right
everybody's a knave so there are lots of
statements like I said these people were
not saying that people were selfish but
rather we should act as if they were
presumably on Prudential grounds
now they assume something rather
different which is quite important and
could be incapacitating to a policymaker
if he weren't paying attention to this
particular assumption and that's this
the Moral Sentiments I'm using Smith's
language obviously and the material
interests could be pursued independently
that's what they assumed
policies which were intended to shape
your behavior by raising the cost or or
the benefits of an activity would not
compromise whatever moral convictions
you had in in to undertake a socially
responsible or pro-social activity so
for example do you think about designing
taxes to try to encourage people not to
smoke cigarettes how does that work
it makes cigarette smoking more
expensive and that's all it does it has
no effect on what the person thinks
according to this view there's no effect
on what they think about smoking whether
it's a good or bad thing it doesn't
convey to them a message oh you're your
fellow citizens think it's actually a
pretty bad thing you're doing and so on
it just changes the costs now
this idea of the the idea that the Moral
Sentiments in the material interest can
can be seen as separable or additive in
designing policies is no-one actually
wrote it down but what they said if you
read carefully Bentham and others who
are doing policy that's obviously what
they thought
strangely John Stuart Mill is the first
person to actually say something pretty
close to it in this passage where he's
defining political economy it does not
treat the whole of man's nature it's
concerned with him solely as a being who
desires to possess wealth it predicts
only such phenomena as take place in
consequence of the pursuit of wealth and
makes the entire it makes entire
abstraction of every other human passion
or motive now that of course gets taken
on board as the economics which
underlies the social policies that are
going to be recommended and this is a
view which has essentially become the
the basis of what we now call
implementation theory or mechanism
design we have here recent but not the
most recent Nobel Prize winners leo
hurvich Meyerson and Maskin and this
idea is not only important in economics
public economics design of economic
policies optimal taxes optimal subsidies
and so on it goes quite beyond that in
terms
of trying to induce kids to stay in
school longer or to in optimal
sentencing policies deterrence and so on
it's also not surprisingly well
represented in law quite a bit before
economists developed the more
sophisticated models of mechanism design
this is Oliver Wendell Holmes anybody
who studies law has read this passage he
announced it to first-year students in
the year 1897 and I think probably every
first-year student in a law school in
America has read this passage if you
want to know the law and nothing else
you must look at it as a bad man who
cares only about the material
consequences which such knowledge
enables him to predict not as a good one
who finds his reasons for conduct
whether inside or out slaw or outside it
in the vague or sanctions of conscience
the law to keep the duty to keep a
contract at common law means a
prediction that you must pay damages if
you do not keep it and nothing else
in other words breaking upfront there's
nothing wrong with breaking a promise
according to this what it says is by the
way he's I'll come back to what he said
right after this as far as the law is
concerned there's nothing wrong with
breaking a promise it's that you know
you may have to pay if you do and in the
passage just before the passage just
after this very short paper that he
wrote the path of law he he goes through
this ecstatic thing about law as an
expression of our morality but he says
in designing laws we have to imagine the
person is thinking just that I have I
have to expect what the penalties may be
okay now the separable 'ti assumption
you remember what that is
these things are can be pursued
independently separate bilities a
mathematical term having to do with
cross derivatives and I may actually get
to showing you what I mean by the
separable ax t but it just means it's
additive for now the Boston firemen in
December 1st 2001 the the Commissioner
the fire commissioner in Boston changed
the sick leave policy they'd had
unlimited sick leaves until then and few
people took them the Boston firemen had
a proud tradition that they came to work
when they're sick or injured
some of them probably there were a few
more sick days on Saturdays and Sundays
and on other days but not very many the
Commissioner then announced that they
would have 15 free work days free sick
days after which their pay would be
docked this is on the 1st of December on
Christmas Day a New Year's Day the
number of people calling in sick
increased fivefold over the previous
year and in the year following the
number of sick days that were clocked by
the Boston firemen were over twice what
they had been the previous year they
responded to the incentive and to the
threat of Oh what happened at Christmas
time by the way is interesting the
commissioner
immediately docked their Christmas bonus
all the guys have called in whatever is
sick or not doesn't matter there were 53
of them and there been five the previous
year and none of them got their
Christmas bonus and they respond to the
next year by apparently everybody
calling in or here's an interesting case
is based on a survey so it's probably
not as interesting in terms of real
world but people have asked both
Palestinian and Israeli students things
about compromises concerning things
which are very almost sacred like
Jerusalem and they were asked well
suppose we have to some compromise we
have to make with the other side that
has asked analogously to both and
suppose that instead of just making this
compromise we were able to secure a
compensation for the for the compromise
that we made and then it asked what
kinds of activities people would feel
likely to undertake under the condition
that a compromise was made or under the
condition that a compromise was made and
compensation was paid on both sides far
more we're willing to undertake violence
if the compensation was paid the
compensation being paid for a sacred
compromising about something sacred made
it even more angering than the
compromise itself the here's an
interesting case just a good luck you
know researchers sometimes have good
luck that's called natural experiments
very often they involve
and studying things that were not
interested in but sometimes we actually
do have natural experiments about things
that are pretty interesting there in the
Norwegian case there was a change in the
catchment area for some hospitals so you
had these two hospital to hospitals with
very different procedures dealing with
the same patients as a matter just of a
redrawing of a line one of them used one
of them used fines and monetary
incentives to prevent overstaying the
bed blocking is what it's called
technically and the other one used moral
suasion and what happened when they when
the finding hospital moved into this
area and the persuasion hospital moved
into summer area you had dramatic shifts
in the amount of bed blocking and the
amount of the length of hospital stays
those who are being fined just responded
in the wrong direction and there's oh
there's a recent paper that's actually
still being written on UK hospitals with
a very similar result the fines
backfiring finally I don't know I don't
know the evidence well enough for this I
think I've read all the papers that
there are I just I I'm not sure it's
really nailed down but I can say that a
great many lawyers think that if you
have explicit provisions in contracts
for what you do in the case of a breach
you actually increase the probability of
a breach people essentially say you know
step right up it's already written there
what we're supposed to do if I want to
basically break my promise of course
even calling it a promise would be
flying in the face of Oliver Wendell
Holmes
now I mentioned these real-world cases
because I know there's some sensible
these experiments are what do they
really show I'll come back to that this
gives you a brief idea of the vast
amount of experimental evidence there is
that the separable 'ti assumption is
wrong I summarized with my co-author
Palani ax the 51 experimental studies of
non-separable ax T overwhelmingly it's
non-separable ax T of the quote wrong
kind where the incentive crowds out the
ethical
sentiment but not always there are about
eight of them in which the opposite
happens actually the incentive seems to
make more salient the ethical or social
or generous motives and clearly we're
going to have to come back to that in
lecture three because that's what I'm
going to say what should we do about all
this we'd like to figure out how to make
these things what are called in
economics technically complements that
is working together synergistically as
opposed to substitutes now the why do
experiments well I mean this is a big
question by the way I understand the
Yale University political science
department had a very interesting
discussion of this what it was at a
month or two ago at end of the fall
semester is that right that I wish I
could have been here you had fantastic
speakers and I would have loved to have
heard you all and your visitors from
outside as well I think the case for
doing experiments here is the control
you have over the environment in which
people are functioning and of the use of
incentives and I say this after a very
long time when I started working on the
problem of how society social structure
alters human preferences and moral
orientations and so on I assumed this
would be pretty easy to to establish
through the use of historical studies
and anthropological studies in which I
was actually fairly well read it having
been an interest of mine ever since I
studied here at Yale in your excellent
program which was then called political
and economic institutions but is now
called EP and II the but in any case as
I pushed really hard on these
ethnographic and historical studies I
found myself rather dissatisfied because
the outlines seem to be consistent with
the hypothesis that incentives or
markets or states or something was
affecting
preferences in a direction but it was
very hard to figure out exactly what was
going on and you very rarely had the
kind of really controlled case where you
can say yes that's pretty good evidence
I'll come back to the question about
what we can infer from the from the
experiments about the real world that's
a very serious question which one that's
not settled but I think it's one on
which we have some evidence
now remember Machiavelli's mistake we've
gotten a little far away from
Machiavelli so here's a mistake by the
way I'm taking liberties with the great
Florentine thinkers writings because he
didn't write anything quite this
specific but this is the idea which I
attribute to him and the people who
follow to him who I named before under
appropriate assumption some combination
of market prices and governmental taxes
and subsidies these these material
incentives could implement socially
desirable social outcomes irrespective
of individual preferences there's set
aside your concern of what people want
take them as they are we can design a
set of property rights taxes subsidies
and so on which will induce them to act
in a way which is morally acceptable to
the society as a whole the consequence
then is that we'd almost entirely
dispensed with virtue although I'm sure
you've figured out something already
which is what about the virtue of the
guy who's setting the incentives that's
another problem but we'll set aside that
problem we almost set aside the problem
of virtue as a foundation of good
government and of course this is a
comfortable move to make because it
averts the embarrassment of taking sides
about people's preferences saying that
in a sense some are better than others
that's something which is generally
considered to be either politically
dangerous or morally repugnant among
people who are liberals now why is this
mistaken well you can imagine what the
argument says incomplete contracts are
ubiquitous
therefore social preferences are
essential and they're becoming more
essential as the economy moves more and
more into areas in which incomplete
contracts are impossible away from the
economy of grain and steel which you can
weigh and measure and put in bushels and
tons into the economy of culture
information and knowledge which is
almost impossible to write contracts in
at least not of the type that are
enforceable as they were with grain and
steel so incomplete contracts are
becoming more important therefore social
preferences are becoming more report
important
in the underpinning of a
high-performance economy and the
resulting market failures that the so
that we have a crescendo or increase in
potential market failures combined with
the fact that we now know after 50 years
of pioneering work by the three Nobel
Prize winners and many other people in
mechanism design that mechanism design
the clever design of policies
interventions is extremely limited in
what it can accomplish in a liberal
society and I'll come back to the limits
of mechanism design in my third lecture
so that so the first problem is we need
these social preferences and we can't
count on these clever incentives to
dispense with them and secondly we have
a problem here which is the incentives
which are the whole key to the mechanism
design paradigm sometimes destroy
ethical motivations upon which the
functioning of the institutions depend
so those are the two problems now I made
the terrible mistake
of naming a lecture Machiavelli's
mistake when I was in Florence and I was
almost burned alive because they're sick
and tired of people saying nasty things
about Machiavelli like you know in the
English language Machiavellian is not a
good thing and and so on so I had three
commentators and each one was more
ferocious than the next I learned
tremendously from them by the way but I
want to say I'm not talking about the
end justifying the means and I'm not
talking about any assumption of a malign
human nature he certainly didn't have a
view that human nature was malign the
idea that all men are wicked remember
was what you should suppose if you're
gonna run the Republic elsewhere in the
discourses and in the prints he says
quite different things if anybody thinks
differently please read I wish you were
here
Erika Boehner's book Machiavelli's
ethics which was just published just a
few months ago it's a fantastic book and
I've learned a lot from her and from it
now let's talk about separable ax T and
how it gets violated so we're gonna
think about the problem of understanding
the effect of an incentive the
incentives called s it varies from
zero to some number it's like a tax or a
subsidy and the incentive is to
contribute where the contribution is
measured by a that's for example
contributing in the public goods game
the citizen has some values presumably
the values would be a vector of values
but there's let's call it one kind of
value here that could be affected
positively or negatively by the
incentive it could also be affected
positively or negatively by what others
do and that's where is that that's a
with a minus superscript and so we have
the utility of the individual that's the
individuals preferences depending on the
incentive the values what they do what
everybody else does and this X is just
anything else that's that's exogenous
and from this we can derive I won't do
it I'm sure you that's a great relief to
you we can derive this what the
individual will choose to do in the
presence of a given level of the the
incentive the values and what everybody
else does here's the picture here maybe
that's just as simple here's the action
those are the values those the
incentives and under the incentive has a
positive effect positive I mean good
could be discouraging smoking or
encouraging the protection of the
environment but I'll just call it a good
action the values have a similar
positive effect but the problem is the
incentives can have either negative or
positive in fact as we saw in the for
example behavior of the Boston firemen
now so the total effect here that's the
effect of changing the incentive on the
action
that's a sum of the direct effect that's
this and the indirect effect that's that
effect there now when we talk about
separable ax t we have the direct effect
is all there is so the effect operating
via the ins by the incentives just isn't
there sometimes we have the total effect
is bigger than the direct effect that's
what I call synergy or complementarity
that's what we're looking for and rarely
get in the experiments oops
and here we have what is much more
common the total effect is less than the
direct effect because this route here
that's a negative effect on values and
sometimes that negative effect can be so
large that you actually get the total
effect being negative so that you
actually do well that's the case of the
Boston firemen isn't it they cranked up
the incentives and they all called in
late so that's a case of what I call
strong crowding out so those are the
cases and we'll find a little bit of all
of them in the in the literature yeah
this will be on the exam
now here's an example of an experiment
that is will be illuminating about how
the various ways in which this process
of crowding out this is a crowding out
case not a crowding in case crowding out
may work this is done by Ellen Bush and
rucola it's a public goods game like the
one I described and they have this here
is the bonus that you're given for
contributing so there's some incentives
to contribute to the public good and
look at the solid dots first with when
there's no incentive to give they give
37 whatever it is I think the total I
forget what the total they could have
given was when there's a low bonus they
give a little more than they gave in the
presence of no incentive so the
incentive worked sort of and when
there's a high bonus they give a lot 53
what are the empty dots the empty dots
are what an entirely selfish person
would do given the incentives well if
with no incentive a selfish person would
have contributed 25 this was not a
public goods game in which the dominant
strategy was to do nothing but rather it
was a public goods game in which the
dominant strategy sorry the strategy
that you should engage in if no one else
contributes is you should sorry if
everybody else contributes 25 you should
contribute 25 under the low incentive
you should contribute 30 if you're
entirely selfish 50 under the high
incentive so essentially this line here
just that gives you how the incentives
are supposed to work according to
economic reasoning for a sell
individual well what do you learn from
this well look when there are no
incentives they gave a lot more than a
selfish person would have given when you
had high incentives they gave almost
exactly the same thing as a selfish
person would have given these two
numbers are not statistically
significantly different from each other
what can we conclude from that that
there was some ethical motivation when
there was no incentive here that was
extinguished is that too strong a word
that was somehow not present when when
the incentive was in force so somehow
the incentive was kind of a message Olly
Olly in for each for your selfish
motives because this is an incentive
problem now by the way I'm sure you're
thinking well I wonder how that works
what was going on in their minds about
that and we have some evidence actually
from fMRI experiments about exactly we
do know what goes on in their minds when
you give them an incentive and I hope
I'll have time to say something about
that so the take-home message here is
interesting the incentive worked right
it worked it increased the contributions
but it did so by destroying and in the
process it destroyed the ethical
commitment to providing for the public
good now of course once I looked at that
experiment that way I I had the
following thought well it looks like
there's two things going on it looks
like we have categorical crowding out
that means the very presence of the
incentive turns off your ethical motives
and the other thing is how big it is
also turns them off well so let's look
at this so this is the same graph done
abstractly suppose this is the how much
the guy would contribute I think it was
what is this thirty seven or something
like that this is what a person would
contribute with no incentives he has
some other regarding preferences and
this here is what a self-regarding
person would contribute and now let's
imagine that we introduced an incentive
well a bunch of stuff can happen the
first thing that can happen is that oh
now you're on the
curve here that is suppose you have an
incentive of Epsilon it's there but it's
really small well you might just then
contribute a lot less because the
presence of the incentive says oh it's
that kind of a problem I'm gonna be
selfish there's a lot of evidence for
that but then if you crank up the
incentive up up would go the the
contribution exactly with the same slope
as is predicted by the economic model
that's what I call categorical crowding
out it could be that we have marginal
crowding out it's not the presence of
the incentive that's the problem it's
the level of the incentive and that just
would mean well there'd be a positive
slope here but it wouldn't be as high as
that one there which is the one which is
unimpeded by this crowding out mechanism
and of course here we can have strong
crowding out here's a case in which you
know the incentive this is strong
marginal crowding out it just means the
line isn't even positive and obviously
you can think of other combinations so
one of the things that my research team
and I did is we went back over all these
experiments and we tried to extract well
what's really going on here are people
responding to the presence of the price
or to the level of the price and we
found some very interesting cases
including there some cases in which
there's categorical crowding in and
again we're going to come back to that
in other words the very fact that the
government says this is something we're
going to find or they or the
experimenter or somebody somehow alerts
people to that and then they actually
that activates their moral concerns
about it so it doesn't necessarily go in
the crowding out way so these are the
those are the terms that I've been using
well here's the previous experiment by
Ireland Bush and rucola
it's here's the 37 they would give in
the absence of the incentive and then
that's what they gave when the incentive
was this and that's what they gave the
incentive was that now here is what we
can interpret as the categorical
crowding out that is taking the slope of
this and extending it back to the
vertical axis we see that
had they been responding like they did
had the incentive in epsilon they would
have contributed something like three or
four or less than what they did so
that's the categorical crowding out and
the lowering of this line the slope of
it is the marginal so in all of these
cases if the experiments done right if
the experiment is done in such a way
that you can predict what a selfish
person would do then you can you can
construct whether or not it's
categorical or marginal and the size of
them the now let's think about why this
is happening and I'm going to do this in
two stages I'm gonna give you some
reasons why it's happening why I think
it's happening today and the next Monday
when we start to say suppose you're a
sophisticated policy maker what would
you have to know much more than I'll say
today much more than I know but at least
I think I have a pretty good idea what
you'd have to know and I'll tell you
what I think we can know about that but
for now I just want to give you some
idea of the basic outlines of what's
going on here framing well-known in
psychology from experimental economics
or also psychological experiments
suppose you have a thing called the
ultimatum game in the ultimatum game
which you'll see a couple of more times
today and the next time in the ultimatum
game I I'm given by the experimenter a
sum of money provisionally and the other
party john castle is the respondent on
the proposer the experimenter asked me
to allocate some sum to John of course I
don't know who he is he's just a number
on my screen and so I have $100 and I
can allocate anything between zero and a
hundred he's uninformed about how much
I've offered him and he could say yes or
no if he says yes he accepts my $1 and I
keep the 99 but I just met John now but
I'll bet that's not what he would do if
he should say no you take your $1 and I
refuse then nobody gets anything
right now there are lots of
interpretations of this game and I'd be
happy to discuss I mean uh discuss all
the possible things that might go on but
I'll bet I bet I predicted John's
reaction and I'll bet I can tell you why
because I gave him one I'd have a
windfall gain of a hundred that I got
from the experimenter he would be angry
and it would be worth at least $1.00 to
punish me and prevent me from getting my
99 in fact in lots of experiments people
are willing to pay half of the you know
they're willing to pay a quarter of the
whole pie even when that's a large
number now so we play this game people
refuse to accept low offers it's just
it's called the game we don't even call
the ultimatum game just you know we
never label these things now suppose we
have a group of experimental subjects
and we say we're gonna play the exchange
game say exactly the same game what
happens then I offer my $1.00 I'm not
saying you would accept but low offers
are much more frequent and guess what
they're much more frequently accepted
now economists please notice the game
hasn't changed the payoffs are exactly
the same what's happened is the label
got changed and this suggests that
somehow people are saying oh it's that
kind of a situation
Andrew shatar a very good experimental
and evolutionary economist at NYU he's
proposed that if you induce competition
between people it has the effect of
essentially what he says is it offers
justifications for actions that an
isolation would be unjustifiable the
market arena is one which is seen as
somehow extraterritorial kind of like a
foreign embassy you know outside the
normal considerations and that's what
his experiments suggest and here's a
famous statement about that about
framing from Thaler and fur ski I think
you're familiar with the idea just there
are cues about the situation and the
situation determines which preferences
you're going to bring to bear on that
problem now framing the situation tells
you what to do
turns on a certain kind of preferences
we have rural Columbian Commons
exploiters that is forest users done by
one Camila Cardenas and his co-authors
they're playing a public goods game just
like the one I described and here we
have these the vertical measure here is
listen to this how far they deviated
from what a selfish person would do it's
not what they contributed it's how much
in this case they're they're taking
stuff from the forest in the experiment
that's it's framed that way so they're
taking less than it would be the selfish
optimum for them to take there they're
protecting the forest and here's what
they do in this game these we have these
two groups and they're doing about the
same they it's framed in terms of months
and they're taking three months less
from the forest of exploiting the forest
now here to there there's a they stop
the game and say oh we're gonna play it
a little differently now and for this
group here these black dots they impose
a fine on anybody who takes more than
the social optimum from the forest and
this group here they don't have no fine
but they just allow them to talk with
each other which they didn't before and
as you can see what's happened here is
the fine starts out being great in fact
they almost hit the social optimum on
the nose and then they find out they can
get away with it
and here we these these here are in
significantly different from zero now
does that remind you of the other thing
by Erland bush and his co-author that is
the fine of course it shifts what a
selfish person would do but it made them
implement exactly what a selfish person
would do whereas here they were staying
out of the forest for three months more
than would have maximized their
well-being
what about here's a second reason why
incentives may oh so what's what's the
explanation there what we don't know you
know people are very hard have a hard
time explaining what they did but it
seems like in the presence of the fine
they said oh this is a maximizing
problem let's maximize and in the
absence of the fine they were trying to
maintain some kind of
ethical relationship with their fellow
forest exploiters probably more famous
is the notion of intrinsic motivation
and the fact that paying may reduce
intrinsic motivation the psychologists
leopard se and Lisbon and others
popularized this about a generation and
a half ago with paying kids to paint
pictures and all kinds of experiments
like that
Dessie suggested in an interesting way
that the underlying mechanism is why do
the kids want to paint less after they
were paid for their paintings than the
kids who weren't paid at all what's
going on there and Dessie said he that
his summary is that feelings of
competence and self-determination that
are associated with intrinsically
motivated behavior or the key thing and
if you're getting paid for
that's diminished now the the that's a
by the way that's still a controversial
view how wide is the domain over the the
kind of problems that that intrinsic
motivation model works for but they've
recently been some very good experiments
here's one by Falcon cost field they we
have people who look like employees and
we have people look like employers and
they're gonna choose some level of
production the employees determine the
whole thing they just determine how much
production is going to happen it's
costly for them and it's beneficial to
the employer so it's as if the employee
is gonna contribute something to the
employer the the agent that is the
employer determines the distribution of
the gains between the two and the
maximum payoff for the for the employee
than the employee is to produce nothing
that's the best for the employee
obviously it's the worst for the
employer now the problem is that there's
an employer and he has a decision that
is he can let the person go ahead and
produce whatever they want or he can
impose a lower bound that the person has
to produce at least this much there are
three lower bounds they're not chosen by
the employer they're imposed by the
experimenter in three different
treatments now the principle that is the
employer if he thinks he's dealing with
selfish individuals he'll assume that
they're going to
perform at the lower bound either zero
in the case of the unbounded case or
whatever the bound is that's all made
available to the employer and so the
principle employer should impose the
bound here's what happened
wait as you can see here's the the this
is the choices this is the contribution
the principle doesn't control they
contribute more than when the principle
does control so in this case it's
obvious that the control backfired
what's going on in the next graph is
this is the effect of control on the
individual and yet there's a group of
people who under the control situation
did more than they would have otherwise
the vast majority of people do less that
is the control imposition of the control
had a negative effect and we're able in
this experiment to extract with a few
assumptions but not very implausible
once the distribution of types so we
have selfish types inequity of Earth's
types control of Earth's types it's a
very interesting case because this
control aversion seems to be a very
major motive and that's consistent with
what deci was saying I think it's a
rather better experiment than most of
the ones that were done earlier now yeah
it's it's very clear what was going on
here the the people who were experienced
the employer quote employer who
controlled experiences it as a sign of
distrust now not very many of the
principles actually controlled that is
they figured out that it was going to
backfire and as you can see those who
did impose the control did very poorly
indeed the almost everyone agreed that
there was a matter of distrust and they
were responding negatively to the
distrust and of course in this case
notice what happened
the ones who the the principal's who
thought that the agents were going to
give the minimum they imposed the
controls and when they imposed the
controls the people gave the minimum so
this is a belief that could persist over
long periods of time because we're going
to have to ask eventually in the third
light
why are these counterproductive
incentives could be so common well
here's a hint
right now which is you may they may
produce a situation in which you never
have them contradicted I've just said
but this is then a third reason and the
last one which I'll talk about today as
to why it is the separable 'ti
assumption may fail and that's this
incentives convey information think
about a principal agent problem
I'm sure you've all studied them
principals select incentives based on
their their own objectives profit
maximization or whatever it is and their
beliefs about how well the agent will
perform the task under every possible
incentive so the I mean the way it's
it's done backwards that is the the
principal derives what's called the best
response function by the agent which is
based on the agent's preferences and
capabilities and so on and then you
choose an incentive given that
relationship
well obviously the incentive that you
choose reveals something about what you
know or think about the agent and so for
example if you if you choose to
supervise somebody very closely
you're probably inferring that they're
they won't do the job without the
supervision they're not well motivated
if you choose to pay them a very large
sum of money for this that may indicate
that it's a lousy job or something else
so you can't avoid giving information
when you impose incentives now of course
some of the kinds of information you may
pass on like for example that you're
generous could be positive and some
could be negative as we saw in the
previous case and I think I'll just pass
by these two slides here I want to talk
about external validity before I end the
evidence if this evidence can be
believed for how people behave in the
street instead of in the lab then it's I
think a very powerful in that indictment
of a dominant policy paradigm namely
based on the separate bility assumption
but these are very odd situations
somebody comes gives you a hundred
dollars and says what are you gonna do
with it well that doesn't happen very
often right these are windfalls now the
the
the new wave of experiments is of course
people have to earn the money that
they're then going to decide on so
that's what's happening one of the
things happening now anonymity we don't
know how anonymous we don't know the
effect of anonymity most of our social
actions are not anonymous many of them
are the anonymity as a lab is a kind of
odd construct it's not like meeting a
stranger on a train and so on we don't
know how people interpret that the
experiment itself is a frame right you
go to some lab whether it's in the field
I mean we've we've experimented in the
Amazon we've experimented in the
highlands of New Guinea and so on but
wherever you go or maybe particularly if
it's in the Amazon or among the hodza
hunter-gatherers in Africa there you
know some anthropology shows up and says
oh we're gonna play this game and they
obviously that's that's a frame that's a
situation
what about subject pools mostly students
not entirely I mean most of my
experiments have been done as I say with
those people around the world who are
not at all students and not part of
industrial societies but maybe we're
getting a false message because the of
the 26,000 subjects in the experiments
that I summarized probably I think I
know the number is something like 17,000
of them were from student pools
interestingly sorry those of you who are
here students tend to be more selfish
than non students now this is not
exactly a nail down fact but I have you
know I I was sort of the past couple of
days I was saying to what extent do you
does everybody in my like you know world
think that you could make a statement
and I first had a double negative that
students are not more generous than non
students and I got back you know I'm an
academic I talk like that but I got back
a lot of messages saying oh no I think
we can we're almost to the point of
saying if there's enough evidence that
people who are non students in all the
games that we've talked about so far
tend to be more generous than students
so the the the bias would not be towards
finding social preferences to be more
important about crowding out I we don't
have any evidence okay so but the
problem still is there the so-called
dick
gives me some money and then it says I'm
supposed to give some part of that money
to another person who's a passive
recipient and typically people take some
some of that money and give it to the
other person sometimes even if it's a
significant amount what are we doin fer
from this that if you're walking down
the street you're gonna just reach in
your pocket and give five dollars to the
first person you run into probably not
well what should we infer from the
dictator game then that people treat
windfalls like that well there was a
dictator game played recently in which
people were asked not to give to a
nameless other person but to a charity
and 60% of the people who actually gave
to the charity in a interview afterwards
said they had never given to a charity
all right that's a problem that I mean
so it suggests that some of the every
not the dictator game is I think
completely almost completely useless
because because of I mean we know a lot
is wrong with it by the way you don't
get such spectacular falsifications in
any of the other games so let me tell
you what we do know let's start with
some of these people here these people
here they fish in lakes in little boats
these people here they fish in the ocean
in large boats there's 12 people they're
carrying that boat there and we did a
whole lot of that is a fair and a
co-author Leibrandt did a bunch of
experiments with these people and with
these people and extraordinarily you
found they behaved behavior and the
games was completely different they're
from the same community the ones that
fish singly are much more selfish than
the ones who fish communally in these
large groups now by the way I'm not
saying that they're generous because
they fish communally I'm just saying
there is that difference let's look at a
better case these are the same area
these guys fish with these nets and the
mesh is large or small these are shrimp
fishers and these are the traps and in
the back there they have little holes
through which the baby shrimps can it
can escape the size of the hole in the
trap is
measure of your commitment to the future
of the stock of shrimps and the
fishermen talk about it all the time
because they take these plastic things
they just take a they put a hot you know
they put a tool in the fire and they
make the hole in the bottom of the thing
themselves they can make it any size
they want and they differ tremendously
and how big the holes are and they talk
about and complain to each other a lot
well fair and lebrandt did did public
goods game and did also an ultimatum
game with these guys these these shrimp
fishermen and found an extremely strong
relationship between how they played the
game how cooperative they were and the
size of the hole they put in their
shrimp traps and their there were some
other things they did another test of
time preference that is impatience and
found the same thing so I mean this is
just tip of the iceberg but the point is
there's a lot of extraordinarily strong
evidence that what's going on in the in
the lab these labs were just people on
the beach right doing these games but
what's going on in the so-called lab is
actually corresponding that what's going
on in the field so somewhere between
thinking it kind of joke a joke about
the dictator game and this stuff here I
mean this is this is something we're
still still working on okay loose ends
these are things I'm going to I'm going
to try to address in the third lecture
things that mechanisms that appeal to
self-interest often implement exactly
the Nash equilibrium that is equally
been predicted by economics that it's
supposed to predict and but in the
absence of the incentives the people
don't act selfish
now that's see that's really interesting
that is the economic prediction works
for if you have incentives you take away
the incentives and they don't act the
way you predict they should act that
suggests incentives are turning off
something the the sometimes the the
adverse effects of the incentives goes
on long after the incentives are
withdrawn I'll give you some
experimental evidence for that and tell
you in the last lecture why I think
that's going on and what effects it
might have incentives often have good
effects you've already seen a case right
remember the public goods game in which
being punished by your peers got
everybody to shape up or
not to decline that's a case in which
incentive namely fines from peers was
working like a dream
whereas fines from the principle against
the agent was somehow working in the
opposite direction backfiring
we're gonna have to figure that one out
because obviously we would like more of
the first and less of the second left to
figure out what's the difference between
those two cases and the last thing it's
a puzzle these counterproductive
incentives that is incentives that
reduce the total surplus between two
parties they're very common I mean well
I'm not discovering exotic incentives
here these are incentives that are very
common in a competitive economy how can
that be
we'll come back to that okay there are
two things that come out of this that I
think are that are worth thinking about
the first is if Humes Constitution for
knaves may produce knaves or at least in
diet induced knavery and if the
Hobbesian state is a recipe for hobbsy
men how can we rethink the self-interest
based policy paradigm supposed to take
account of both the importance and the
fragility of civic mindedness
that's the subject of the last lecture
but Thursday I'm going to consider the
following
if explicit incentives that form the
foundation of markets and public
economics if these crowd out the virtues
necessary for the function of these very
same markets modern economy and polity
then are we to conclude that the
resulting society namely Liberal
Democratic capitalism is dynamically
unstable in the sense that in the very
long run it doesn't sustain the
individual values upon which it's
functioning depends this is not an
invention
Edmund Burke is not the first to write
this but he's the one who warned us of
the age of Safa stirrers and economists
namely we would say now but actually he
was protesting an insult to the Queen in
a passage in reflections on the French
Revolution and he was withholding from
France the approval of what they had
done until I was informed of how this
Liberty might be combined with
government with public force with
discipline and obedience of armies and
with the collection of an effective and
all distributed revenue with the
solidity for property and peace and
order with civil and social manners
without them Liberty is not a benefit
while it lasts and it is not likely to
continue long the age of chivalry has
gone that of Safa stirs economists and
calculators has succeeded and he goes on
to say the decent drapery of life has
been torn off by the way if that sounds
a little like some passages of marx and
engels in the communist manifesto or if
it sounds almost exactly like passages
in de Tocqueville's
democracy in America you've read your
books well they all said things like
this things remarkably close to this
idea that the system is working in a way
that's destroying its moral foundations
that's our topic for Thursday thank you
very much for your attention I'd like to
thank no it's not please
I want to thank of course john castle
for making this this possible but i've
had a very large number remarkably
because i don't spend all my time at
yale university although i did graduate
from here it's great to be back in this
library where i spent roughly between 8
a.m. and 12 p.m. for four years yeah I
was I was a nerd of the of the ultimate
kind but I have I received the help of
lots of people in this work as well as
from the Santa Fe Institute and the
University of